for the main course remember and olive
all - hot pan remove the fat for mistake
roll out thin and feeding by quickly on
both sides then set aside into the same
pan add chopped slots and seasoned apps
like mushrooms Inaba butter and crushed
garlic then add a splash of Worcester
sauce and Dijon mustard pour a dash of
brandy and flambe once the alcohol has
burnt off squirrel the juices add the
cream and stir in chopped parsley return
the steaks and cook espresso potatoes
heat oil slice the Powerball potatoes in
half and place cut slide down season add
crushed garlic and rosemary plate up and
spoon the sauce over the steak steak
Diane with soda potatoes and peas done
and it'll be one of my favorite cuts of
all time packed with flavor
salt pepper hot pan olive oil make sure
you get a really nice color on the steak
garlic rosemary thyme bay leaf chicken
stock the secret isn't even nice and
moist
[Applause]
Rhett whilst the state's absorbing the
stock when I made the gremolata lemon
zest parsley capers season mix those
packed with flavor the charm
[Music]
gremolata
sauce olive oil laughing my perfect way
of eating facilitate [ __ ] delicious
ham roasted filet of beef with gamma
Lata done and now for my wild card I was
fed up with her unbalanced boring gluten
free diet she may not have eaten meat
for three years but now she thinks she's
ready to give it another go
so I'm thrown in at the deep end with a
delicious protein rich steak and I see
the kind of beef it's red in Asia
yeah it's fed on grass in the summer
Swedes and turnip in the winter so it's
a proper organic beef when I did eat me
over to try and eat organic I don't like
the way no was a mass-produced you know
stand strong on that one nor do i how'd
you like your beef how'd you like it
cooked medium yeah yeah fine so what
could be things ever okay for the
dressing Sherlock I believe that good
quality lean meat is a key part of a
healthy diet so I'm hoping this dish
will help Hannah back on the road to
recovery and over the safe a delicious
tarragon dressing should make her first
finish taking years and it will easier
to deal with
that's what a spicy marinade targa we
just cut one Valley I give it a stir and
add to the steak delicious I'm going to
do a spoon that over so the beef starts
to cool down we absorb all that amazing
flavor finally finish the console with
coriander and is ready to go
[Music]
yours media I can't believe you can put
so much different flavors and tastes
Assunta counselor I don't quite manage
to take on the base you put the most
amazing energy into looking after these
animals so you need protein yeah I'm
feeling good better salmon do you think
I'm almost off of me
it's not quite ready for the the red
meat don't you worry about that
I'll eat it if you want a new twist on a
favorite dish spice it up with chili my
next recipe it's super simple to make
but has wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad chili if you
use them constantly that can really add
a new dimension to the style of cooking
but the real trick is finding that
balance of flavors that really suits you
because that's the most important
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly seasoned steak generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the third line
take the third on average literally 20
minutes if we won't cook them so you get
such a room-temperature they cook more
evenly but more importantly you can
actually season right inside the steak
it's a little bit of fat down here
seasoned that as well because that is
what we want to roast and get that
really nice and render olive oil in a
tablespoon roll that rounds as it starts
to smoke in with the steak into pan and
lay away again into the pan and lay away
if you don't hear that noise the many of
those states with the pan don't put them
in so they think we're now getting that
color on the steak turning it once and
once only and cooking it for two and a
half minutes each side what I want to do
is to get that but a fat render so it
adds a lot more flavor its hold just
take down like that and that starts to
melt the fat which makes it so much more
tender
there should be no white fat left
anywhere turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so we spent less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important now to fingers touch it goes
in just rare I'm happy to be rare
because by the time I let them rest then
we go back the medium rare or continue
cooking out onto the plate and let them
rest one
so you get my juices over
don't waste that really important next
the spicy dressing take the seeds out of
a chili to reduce the heat by rubbing it
in your hands and tapping until the
seeds fall out cut in half and just chop
it thin garlic and chili works
brilliantly a quick way of peeling it
get your knife and just slam it down
pops out very quickly in little touch a
salt rub start going around the circle
space and see it puree
nice hit it off now if we've got the
heating there from the chili and that
richness from the garlic 2 teaspoons of
palm sugar this is where it starts to
have that nice sweet sour effect fish
sauce fresh lime this is a simple fresh
chili dressing and it was something I
fell in love with in Vietnam and
Cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix uses all the
sugar quick taste
mmm Wow right vegetables a great fuss
free way to get super thin ribbons of
carrot is to use a veg peeler when
they're that thing they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
[Music]
Robert give another dimension of this
Alice reads a banana a lot they are
incredibly mellow sweet across to chop
up the Shalon and mix that through what
some sweetness in there now that will
bind tomatoes slice them in half
tomatoes in shallow radish carrots and
tomatoes next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and finally there's a fresh mint
as young men so you don't need to take
all those stalks off you do is hold a
bunch upside down and then take it for a
little trim and just chop that one
through you know that nice mint is
Salle's color tale screams of dressing
don't flood the cellar with a dressing
nauzad but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chilli and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around the sellers beautiful
on to the plate because things rest it
now nice and medium-rare a little bit of
fat where you want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that served
its purpose it's kept that staying nice
and moist
just slice then with the grade almost
like slicing through butter not in size
beautiful pink it's like to be too
thinly then it goes stone-cold and more
importantly all the goodness runs out of
it nice thick slices get the beef start
placing it around you sell it take a
little teaspoon on your dressing the
rest of your salad bit back on top we'll
finish it off with some toasted peanuts
eat up then now there's not a really
toasted nut despont
get on a pan and just crush
what does cool down just run them
through with a knife you can hear our
quads they are another texture another
taste the phallus and then from there
sprinkle
and then finally say that just finish
with a little tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well texture
spicy beef sellers
[Music]
steak sandwiches for me the secret of a
great brunch is fun and casual fuss free
cooking and everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich you
want the rolls-royce of beef it has to
be Phillips now seasoned it beautifully
I like to open up the top of that mill
to increase the size of the tip in the
steak so it gives that for the heat
I think chunks you just roll now nicely
all the way around now slice the garlic
in half pants nice and hot olive oil in
hold the fake and just place it into the
pan don't drop it at the front of the
pan there's still the Pam Ford took the
back of a sage jewel surface now roll it
back and stare underneath neck my garlic
and roast that garlic thyme fry that
time I want to hear it we're not looking
for a lot of color cause you're going to
dry out and fill it so just one end send
it back down and stare the other ending
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic there they stopped you fill it
and put that on top of your garlic
butter in take a spoon fills the pan
gently lift up and bake but that printed
garlic lime flavor the things of a cook
evenly because it's down a little a
little bit in the oven eight to ten
minutes pan on the relish you think of a
steak sandwich you think of a sort of
nice heated tomato relish to make the
relish finely diced red onion ring
finger rule one in front to behind
through from shop Wow
next roughly chop a Chile keeping the
seeds in for extra heat but offer the
olive oil into a pan
onion chili
generally olive oil when I sort of rich
silky relish from there so your closet
you can't just use red tomato for these
yellow and red make a perfect
combination
now put a salt in red and then roast
those can either go take your wooden
spoon and just pull up break them up on
some skin blister the holes Martha just
started to release all that really nice
sweet texture that was teaspoon show
vinegar gives that nice acidic balance
the sweetness of its masters turn down
the gas and just let them sort of stew
perfectly now steaks damage would not be
complete unless it had the most amazing
mustard mayonnaise simply have three
tablespoons of mayonnaise two three
teaspoons of whole-grain mustard
[Music]
I've got the relish almost down to like
a really nice Jam now I want to make
that relation a litte bit more fragrance
some basil slice it through spring front
as we know beautiful
I'll give it I see if my crowns on
trying to take it out now is incredible
just safe one more time
but it
[Music]
such is quite soft in the center so
coming up the mid-rare let it rest the
same time you cooked it it'll be nice
and pink evenly throughout the stage to
make my sandwich
I'm going to char grill some sliced G
patter bread seasoned it nicely just a
little drizzle of olive oil
I'll get that bread nice and crispy pan
nice and hot bread in push it down smell
is amazing that char sort of charcoal
flavor would you want those marks on the
bread just stop the bread from becoming
soggy and look at this here
it is stunning on
slice it gently one beautiful spice
we're nice and pink all the way through
the beef is so soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
the knife do the work take some of it of
mayonnaise spread that the back of the
spoon on both side next lettuce take
that beautiful slice of beef Wow and
then relish and top it up these and just
slice a sandwich in half each now bats
are called a steak sandwich
trust me service sublime sandwich for
brunch and you put a smile on everyone's
face
[Music]